hello everyone I hope you're all
enjoying your Saturday because we are
back at the Kuppa Blanca saga which
means we are back at the 1914 tournament
of some Peterburg I toss a real kappa
blanka vs. dogs Ebert Arash now this is
the fourth time purple Anka faces
ciguatera first three times he faced him
with the black pieces all three games
were drawn sorry no the third game kappa
blanka was able to win so in there you
know there and encounters a cup of Wonka
is the one point in the lead so a good
opportunity for Siebert Arash to
equalize but he has the black pieces
here and capablanca was having the
perfect tournament so far those who have
been following at the first part of the
tournament Capablanca won with one and a
half point ahead of everyone else but
now in the second part of the tournament
after four excellent games kappa blanka
loses a game to world chess champion
Emanuel Lasker a brilliant game work of
a Blanca made the one one mistake and
it's all a score needed to create this
brilliancy it says the Lasker says you
know without without error there can be
no brilliancy but let's see how
capablanca coped with it this is a round
after that loss against divine Alaska so
let's check it out I still haven't
gotten that book by tottered a great
tournament of 1914 but I'm still hoping
it will arrive before we actually ended
the capablanca saga so without further
ado let's check out the dis game cup of
lanka has the white pieces and he opens
with E 4 we have E 5 and Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and now not immediately but
should be v first Knight to c3 we're
going into the four Knights game Knight
to f6 and now Bishop to b5 the Spanish
variation of the four Knights and the
bishop to be four by towers the so
called the double Spanish variation we
have castles by kappa blanka castles by
tirage and now d3 Bishop captures on c3
be captures on c3 sorry me chapters on
c3 and now comes d5 by tar so Tara
already gives up the bishop prepare for
some nice initiative in the center but
Capablanca decides to give back the
bishop pair and you know grab a pawn
with Bishop captures on c6 b captures
and c6 and not Knight captures on e5 and
here you could go
for D captors on e4 but after rook to e1
e capture Sandy's receipt after Sandy
three white gives back the pawn but
retains a better pawn structure and you
know which would the CC point it will be
somewhat easier for whites to play this
so after 95 the turret goes for Queen to
d6 a nice developing move attacks couple
Blancas night and now Bishop to f4 this
is something Tara had prepared and rook
to e8 a brilliant move by Tara it has
been played several times after this
game also which comes as a double attack
against the knight on e5 and if you look
at it you would think oh surely there
are some nice nasty discoveries here
well not really the only the useful
discovery that you might think of is
maybe nice the g6 but after this you're
better Panna for is protected the Queen
cannot capture it but you're not really
attacking anything after the Queen moves
you just have to move back tonight you
could go e5 but then after Knight moves
your point is now under attack twice the
night we'll have to move Knight h4 and
now after Queen captures black will grab
a pawn and also you're a pawn is now
attacked three times by rope Knight and
queen so a couple Lanka doesn't go for
any nasty discoveries rather he goes
Queen to f3 he finds a different idea
and okay we have D captures D captors
and now rook captures on in five so
giving up a rook for two pieces and now
if Blanca just grabs it there's no
serious compensation here black just is
basically up material to pieces for a
rook
so first couple longer goes rook F the
d1 now with the idea let's save go if
Queen e7 only then Capablanca captures
and then white will have some threats
along the bank rank as the back rank is
somewhat weak terror still hasn't
developed his light square bishop after
the knight blocks you could have some
nasty ideas with Queen to f4
trying to sacrifice the Queen for for a
nice background checkmate and even after
27 Queen captures on c7 now you could
continue offering the Queen and so on
and so on and of course like I still
cannot capture due to checkmate but it
would give white or a very nice game so
after rook after the one Tara goes for
Bishop to g4 he decides you know there's
no time to leave any Bank right
weaknesses and here a couple Blanca
well we're not I'm gonna tell you what
couple on our plate here but this is
definitely the crucial position of the
game imagine you're playing this
position against Arash you know forget
all about that you've just lost the
previous game to world champion emmanuel
ask her that I'll just play Bishop to g4
now you have the white pieces of wood
you play here just you know just pause
the video here and you know try to get
in the mood of the game I'll give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
still haven't decided whether to try it
or not for those of you who found the
nice continuation congratulations you
have really gotten into the mood of the
game and for those who just wanna enjoy
the show the best idea here would be
rout captures on these six just grabbing
the Queen and then go into a series of
exchanges for example Bishop captures
rook captures on f6 now G captures
Bishop captures on e5 f captures on e5
and after G captures on f3 we would have
this endgame a rockin game where
capablanca is still up upon but
capablanca has a double C pawn and a
double F pawn which basically it's a you
know most likely it would be played out
to a draw but it's there's no bedroom
there's no better idea than going for
this kappa blanka after this Bishop to
g4 went Queen to g3 and Queen to g3 is
just a blunder one of the one of couple
one has the biggest blunders in his
entire career so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the winning idea
for for dr. ziggurat RS here now I will
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just defeated
host a row kappa blanka not yet but you
you have gotten a winning advantage and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show Bishop captures on d1 this is
the problem and a thought here that okay
if tariffs just for example moves the
Queen there there's nowhere to go to
move the Queen as you're gonna lose the
rook but after a bunch of characters on
d1
this was played Bishop captures on e5
was played and now comes the move that
you had to find what happens after
captors on e5 here come Lanka thought
okay for Queen d7 then I can capture on
f6 I'm already threatening checkmate
black has to react to this most likely
queen g4 would come to defend the bishop
on d2 as well as prevent checkmate and
after captures captures we would have
this endgame there's a pass the move
where it's the bishops of opposite
colors but Cooper monk are still up upon
it's a nice nice eeep on f3 will be
played and it will be a position
capablanca will enjoy it's hard to say
if you will be able to push it for a win
but you know it's a nice position but
here after this Bishop captures an e5
move comes a move capablanca missed and
it's the move tires played and I hope
everyone found it Queen to d2 and now
Capablanca is in big problems now you
don't have any any time to do anything
due to Queen to e1 checkmate so first
you have to prevent Queen to a1
checkmate capablanca does so by playing
f3 and okay we have nice to h5 now a
very important move prevents checkmate
on g7 and also forces the Queen to move
back and the Queen can't move back just
anywhere the Queen still has to keep an
eye on d1 square so Queen to f2 and now
tires just trades off Queen's Queen
captures we have King captures and
Bishop captures on c2 so what do we have
here the World Cup of Lanka will grab
the c7 pawn but all-in-all
Tarrasch is up a whole piece which is
insane this is only move 18 and couple
monk are basically blundered a piece
it's okay
couple monk are still you know he's not
interested in resigning he just lost the
previous game to roll champion Emmanuel
ask her rock the c1 with Bishop to a4
and now Bishop captures on c7 cover
Blanca all night
now try everything and anything to not
lose this game rook the c8 attacking the
bishop and now rook to be one still
saying that a parish has some background
weaknesses so of course you cannot
capture we have Bishop to b5 blocking of
the B file and now comes Luke to d1
again you cannot capture because rook to
the edge checkmate so King - FA - now
the King has an escape square on e7 and
Bishop to e5 finally getting out of the
way King the East 7 and now a 4 would
the idea that if Bishop captures the
rook to a
we'll pick up the a 7.0 but still all
trades favor black as black is still up
a piece tariffs doesn't even allow this
activity for capablanca Bishop to c4 is
played and now comes a rook to d4
attacking the bishop
we have Bishop to e6 and now rook to be
four again the Blancas bishop very
nicely controlling this diagonal rook
the b7 is the idea capablanca wants to
win the a7 point and then maybe just
maybe his passport i will be enough to
compensate for the for the loss of a
piece and for as long as stars tonight
remains on h5 it's really not not too
you know a valid member of this game but
okay Bishop to d7 we have looked to b7
now attacking the a7 pond and rook to e8
so for now couple Lanka is doing very
nicely in this game even though he's
down a piece the rook is stuck guarding
the a7 pawn the bishop pinned it cannot
move and the knight really not doing all
that much King 3:3 Capablanca brings the
King into the game and now finally it's
time for Tata to introduce the knight
back into the game Knight f6 we have a
five backup Blanca and now comes King to
EA unpinning
and here you might think okay first a
six then there should be four we're
gonna go after this own pawn but if you
push a six Bishop c8 higher losing that
bone either way so after King e8 Bishop
to b4 immediately attacking the SL pawn
and now just a six this is how tariff
defends it you want to put it on light
squares couple monk on Lee has a dark
square bishop we have f4 by Capablanca
and now comes a very nice move just a
wonderful tactic that allows the last
card to trade down one more piece c5 and
now what do you do
the problem is if you capture it Knight
captures on e4
when no not wins but you know pretty
much white loses any hope of ever
drawing this game because now captures
Czech picks up the rook and on the other
hand if you go something like a mission
if I've done Knight g4 will pick up the
bishop and also you will have to mess up
your pawn structure
so after c5 we have Bishop captures and
f6g captures on f6 and now look the b6
pressuring the ASX pawn but also
attacking the f6 pawn so kappa blanka
doing some progress but hard to say if
it will be enough but there is one idea
that
Capablanca life and we're gonna get to
that very soon King g7 of course
defending the f6 pawn and now f5
limiting the mobility of tariffs bishop
we have Bishop to b5 now limiting the
mobility of the rook also defending the
expansion now the rook on a8 can move we
have G for rook to d8 you know take a
grabbing hold of the open file and King
to f4 we have rook to d1 there was no
stopping this rook from from
infiltrating and out comes h4 and now h6
looked a b7 check we have king to f8 and
now comes look to c7 attacking the c5
pawn and here c4 and it seems like an
odd thing to do while I mean it's a very
nice structure there's no way white can
ever grab anything here how about on the
other hand it's your Bishop is now
mostly a pawn here on the Queen side but
it's not a problem with this blockade
here on the Queen side it will be very
easy for Taurus rook to pick up all the
points here on the Queen side and then I
mean it's just over
but capablanca still has some poison to
the position g5 h captures h captures
and now first look to f1 check King g4
rook g1 check not will win the g5 pawn
king f4 and now F captures and g5 with
check but King g5 Capablanca still has
some hopes if this king can get home the
way to f6 maybe there will be some ideas
but you know it's still still early to
tell rook e1 now preventing the King
from infiltrating because you will lose
d4 pawn about kappa blanka does it
anyway we have king to f6 now d f7 pawn
will fall
we have rook captures any for rook
captures on f7 would to check king 38
and now comes a rock to g7 going after
the pawn
g4 and now rook to g5
Bishop to c6 now the bishop is coming to
d5 to control all of these squares you
don't want to allow this past bone to
start marching forward we have King g7
preparing f6 f7 and f8 and what tariffs
of course blocks it with Bishop to d5
now if f6 Justin Bishop to f7 and
there's no contract for white so a
couple Lanka tries look to g6 it goes
after the a6 pawn but now first
rook to e7 check King to h6 and now
Bishop to e4 and here kappa blanka
decides to grab the g4 one is it's very
fast dangerous black pawn rook captures
we have Bishop captures on f5 and now
rook captures on c4 we have Luke to e5
and now comes the King to g5 here kappa
blanka is trying to trick a tie rush
into going Bishop to e6 check and this
would be an unfortunate into the towers
game because after king f6 Bishop
capture screen captures this is a draw
it doesn't matter even even if white
head and no points it's still a draw
because of well a1 is a dark square you
have a light square bishop there is no
way you will ever be able to promote the
de-spawn so after g5 Bishop to d3 check
by Irish we have King to f4 now
attacking the rook but now comes Luke to
f5 check King to g4 still in time to
grab the rook if Bishop captures rook
comes about of course that doesn't work
so rook captures on a5 and here we have
looked at D for attacking the bishop
Bishop e5 and now King to f4 so here a
couple Blanca still has hopes if
capablanca somehow manages to trade off
rooks then black is left only with this
outside passed pawn which Queen's on a
dark square and this will be a drawn
endgame if capablanca just puts his King
on a1 there's no way black can ever push
him away from there
if Capablanca is able to exchange rooks
of course rook to a3 attacks the pawn c4
now attacks the bishop and advances
Bishop d7 and now King g5
we have King to d8 and now comes Luke to
d2
King to c7 and now King to d4 and now a5
black starts pushing his own passport as
well
rook to d3 and now of course we already
mentioned if captures captures it's a
draw
there is no way black can ever push the
white king of off of the a1 square I
will repeat this a few times just in
case some real beginners you know are
starting to enjoy chess rook the d3 now
comes Luke 2 a1 just getting the rock
colored way in king c3 Luke 2 c1 check
King to beat you and now rook to h1 we
have looked at the
going after the pawn now comes a for the
bishop nicely protects the pond there we
have looked the d2 now
preventing any checks here but now brush
up to c6 sorry
Bishop to c6 we have King to a2 and
knock on skin to b6 now black will
slowly but surely you know get his King
as deep into the position as possible
rugby to check with King c5 and now
comes look to be one again
acaba Blanca tries to trade rooks but of
course Tosh isn't interested rook h3
with rook the g1 and now kink captures
on c4 finally look the c1 check we have
King Tubby 5 and now rook the b1 check
King c5 rook c1 check cutter Lanka will
continue checking the black king you
know it's as close to a draw as he can
get
rugby 1 check and now rush up to d5
check King Tubby - and now a3 check the
bishop now controlling the light squares
the King has to move King to a1 and now
comes King to c5 we looked to see one
check now Bishop to c4 and now you can
see that the bishop and the pond create
a wall against the white king so the
whitening cannot approach anywhere near
we have looked the g1 and not rook to h2
now rook also helping out we looked the
g5 check King to b4 and now comes look
back to g1 not allowing of course rook
h1 to come with checkmate rook to a2 now
this comes with check King to be one and
now rook to d2 and here kappa blanka
just play came to a-1 but it was also in
this position and move 83 that josé raúl
capablanca
resigned at the game so quite quite a
tragic tragic runs that's why I decided
to choose this quote above the board by
none other than Ziggler Terrace who
mentions this in his book that
misfortune seldom comes alone after that
small mistake against Lasker in the
previous round our couple uncle just
should have captured the bishop and then
you know take away the d4 square from
last night here again KABOOOM Anka
misses that continuation that basically
either draws the game or Leafs
capablanca with a slightly better
endgame but instead he just you know get
gives up a fool
peace which is unreal for for kappa
blanka you know now one of one of the
definitely the strongest players in the
world at the time this tournament was
played at the 1914 tournament of some
Peterburg to blunder a piece on move 18
simply simply incredible and no doubt to
capablanca was well he was still
probably in his thoughts in the game
against Alaska in the previous round so
even even you know such a legend like
Kosovo capablanca was not immune to such
things so you know anytime it happens to
you and it will you know don't be a beat
yourself too hard about it but yeah what
did he resign well now after the king is
here after Bishop to d3 there's really
not all that much you can do king b3 is
coming in the rook to a2 will be
checkmate so white could try try a
couple of things for example Roop to see
one after bishop to see to the bishop
still blocks to be one square from the
rook and now you whatever you play let's
say rook e1 king b3 is coming you want
to deliver checkmate after rook III
check Bishop d3 is coming and after rook
e1 now just rook a to check or this will
be checkmate and although there were a
few possibilities for example let's say
rook to c1 then let's say King b3 and
now rook c3 check would allow for some
stale meeting ideas now of course it
stars captures then it's a stalemate at
the rook and pawn and the bishop control
all of the vital squares but even if
this happened tartar doesn't have to
really capture the routine Joe smoking
before and then after rugby three check
he will still not capture King c4 rooks
III check and then after King before you
will no longer be able to you know
trying to stalemate as any check now
we'll just be captured by the bishop or
or something but there was no way to go
for any more tricks so Kombucha just
decided to resign after came to a 1 but
yet once again it and I will repeat this
because it will be very important when
you will be telling the story of the
1914 tournament you know to your friends
and family after this Bishop to g4 move
Capablanca just had to do this and he
goes into into a slightly better endgame
after capture she just go
actors like we mentioned captures
captures captures captures captures and
it's it's like that you know easy game
for a couple of Blancas you know that
they can probably even just agree to a
draw here
but after virtual to do 4123 and now you
know a pure blunder of a piece
incredible but yeah what do you do
that's that's chess you know things
happen
ah yeah now that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and that you were
enjoying my coverage of the couple
Blanca saga so far I would like to thank
you very much Murdoch Simone Johansson
Daniel Miller Barry fortune and Luis
Felipe Iago for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon with
some more hopefully some more
interesting content
two more games remaining in the 94 the
internment of son Peter Berg so you know
stay tuned it will be it will be you
know crazy so thank you all and have an
excellent rest of your Saturday